my instinct is to hide my instinct is to
not be seen because then I can't be
ridiculed then no one can judge me then
no one can say that this was stupid or
this was bad
can we talk about having self-confidence
to have your own voice that has that
changed since you've moved around the
U.S I love that question
um because
it's something that I teach now because
I think in Hollywood in particular
you really need to be confident in who
you are I think I think a lot of us who
come out to the industry I've just
noticed a lot of people struggle with
self-confidence self-esteem self-love
and I think that because our industry is
so unstructured because there's such
um a lack of a clear point A to point B
sometimes like it can just always be
very amorphous for all of us whether
you're successful or not whether you get
that external validation from the
industry or not it is difficult to not
take some of the rejections and the
failures personally and it's easy to
like internalize those things because I
so I think it's really important whether
you do it before you enter the industry
or while you're in it to really Center
and understand how important it is to
have a sense of value in yourself have a
sense of self-love for yourself that is
not only a reflection of what you
produce
um whether you produce things or not
whether you did great today or not
whether the performance went well or not
there has to be a a foundation of
self-love and I really struggle with
that I really did not have a lot of
self-confidence when I first got to
Hollywood and I felt that it was
something that really held me back it
made me nervous when I talked to my
managers and my agents
um it made me feel like I couldn't
really push back with my lawyer it made
me feel like I struggled with a lot of
imposter syndrome when it came to being
in the writer's room and not really
feeling like I belong there and not
really feeling like I deserve the seat
at the table now whether or not those
things were true the fact of the matter
is that I was there
and that I did have a a value to give my
voice and my perspective and my history
all those things are valuable
um and those things are valuable no
matter what and that's it
those things are valuable no matter what
you are valuable no matter what and you
have to walk around understanding that
knowing that because as soon as you
start to as soon as you get into
adulthood and you start to look to the
world to fill that void and to give you
that validation for somebody to tell you
that you have value
once you're waiting for that then to me
it feels like an open wound that can
never really be healed because
now you have the habit of like filling
that void with that outside validation
instead of the habit of filling that
void with your own validation or not
having that void at all because you've
given yourself that self-love and that
self-validation and I think what it
really comes down to is just
I think self-esteem is about like
self-love
um
and
putting work into things that you care
about showing up for yourself
I think
um
I think it's just incredibly important
to
practice self-compassion
um and being compassionate with yourself
and
knowing that you're worthy of compassion
whether you produce things or not
because we're in a very capitalist
society that Associates all of our value
with what we produce and I think this
can be very damaging to the psyche and
to the self and I think the the way that
I found to combat that is with
self-compassion is by giving myself the
love that I need whether it's by not
criticizing myself or not doing
something well enough
um
letting myself rest when I'm tired
letting myself create be in front of
people letting myself be seen because I
think that you know I'm safe to be seen
you know so much of this is about you
know this internal mental
um tape that's going on that a lot of us
have of like you're not good enough
you're not worthy you're not this and
that voice needs to be interrupted and
acknowledged and looked at and not just
allowed to run wild that voice needs to
be like hey
what where is that coming from what is
this you know
um I'm not worthy you notice it so
there's this thing that I teach in my
course that I learned from um
Tara Brock uh she has this book called
radical acceptance that I really love
and her book is the thing that
introduced self-compassion to me and she
has this technique that she calls rain
where she teaches you how to implement
self-compassion in the moment and it's
very simple so it's just rain stands for
recognize allow
investigate nurture
and when she talks about recognize she
she means to recognize what she calls
the trance of unworthiness so once you
have that tape going on in your mind I'm
not good enough it's not going to be
good they're not going to like it
whether you're going in for a pitch or
whatever it is that's going on in your
mind if it's in your relationship he
doesn't really like me she doesn't
really like me whatever that's going on
in your mind recognize that I'm in the
trance
of unworthiness allow you don't need to
fight this this feeling of whatever the
unworthiness is you don't need to find
it you can allow it you can let it be
there
investigate where is it coming from why
is it there why don't I feel like I
belong here why don't I feel like this
because then you think about oh this
this happened and that made me feel like
that
is it true am I still in that situation
am I in a completely different place am
I just replaying a pattern that kept me
safe a long time ago do I need this
pattern anymore can I continue on
without it nurture give yourself the
compassion you need it's okay you need
rest you've been through a lot whatever
the the compassionate voice that you
need that compassionate parent figure
that you maybe didn't have like you give
it to yourself in that moment and once
you're doing this rain technique a lot
I've been able to do it in like two
seconds now like you know I'll recognize
I'm I'm in a bad place I'll allow it
I'll investigate it I'll nurture it and
I'll move forward and this practice of
self-compassion turns very slowly into
self-love and which turns into
self-confidence because once you're able
to like get past this negative self-talk
you can get to the actual work you know
you can get to the ACT actual creating
because a lot of that I think is just
like in the way of us living our most
authentic best
creative lives so
that's the big lesson that I've learned
is that like this self-confidence is
foundational to your success and your
happiness and your longevity and the way
to get to it is to start with
self-compassion
and that's great is that you said Tara
Brock Tara Brock
um beautiful yeah uh radical acceptance
and what does allowing yourself to be
seen what does that mean
so this is something that
I don't know why we struggle with it so
much I know I've struggled with it a ton
I have the
um
I just my instinct is to hide my
instinct is to not be seen because then
I can't be ridiculed then no one can
judge me then no one can say that this
was stupid or this was bad you know
putting out my short film my witchers
short film I was like oh my God they're
gonna think it's so dumb but it's like
but I think it's fun so I'm gonna have
to put it out and also I want to see I
want this was my first directing project
and I need to gauge where I am as a
director I need to get feedback from the
world about where I am so I'm gonna have
to be able to be I'm gonna have to be
seen well you know and
it has been very difficult for me to be
seen in the past uh but I've done a lot
of that rain I've done a lot of like
recognizing allowing investigating and
nurturing whatever it is
um whatever this fear is whatever this
feeling of unworthiness is that has kept
me hiding
um and it's been I think it's been
profound I think it's an important
experience to go through like if you
have something that you want to create
I almost think that it is a
invitation to love yourself
and I don't know how to explain it but I
just think that like creation is such a
existential process like it is such a
like we're human beings and as human
beings like we have the ability to make
things to write things to come up with
stories
um to connect with people in that way
and I think that um
that fear of being seen is all about
lacking a sense of safety and I feel
like it's about creating a sense of
safety for yourself by doing you know
whatever the thing whatever it is that
you need whether that is
practicing being seen practicing being
seen as yourself whatever you need for
that sometimes the being seen is what
you need